Bavarian State premier horse to Z alpha
mingling in a B attempt in bada
heightened hug with a demeanor that
borders on regal he exudes the sort of
confidence that comes from knowing he's
a shoo-in for re-election on September
the 15th his conservative Christian
social Union Party is riding high he
shall be monopoly dish you in the early
days of my political life the very was
one of the most underperforming states
in west germany the upswing came
gradually and de france yosef strauss
and edmund stoiber when indeed myself it
led to where we are today on top it took
time but we got there thanks to our own
advice the CSU has been in power in
bavaria for over five decades often with
an absolute majority the mood in the
beer tent is buoyant and
self-congratulatory bavaria might look
to the future but tradition still
matters the party isn't called the
Christian social Union for nothing Eddie
says off valve society needs values
Bavaria is and remains a Christian state
we won't be introducing Muslim public
holidays where Christians my friends
by the right inhaler isn't a dilek spa
town in the foothills of the Alps not
far from the Austrian border
historically its wealth came from its
salt works today it lives mainly off
tourism like most of the varia its
thriving its economy is booming there's
practically no unemployment CSU mayor
Hobart lukna knows exactly how to
explain his party's appeal it's easy
Danish bit silly clean teapot I the CSU
doesn't appeal to a specific demographic
it has a broad base that's why it has
such a wide reach in Bavaria in order
deputy mayor Manfred Adelina is a Social
Democrat which makes him a lot less
popular invite viking hall and across
the state the party doesn't stand much
of a chance in the upcoming state
elections it's frontrunner candidate
Christian odor is currently polling less
than twenty percent überall Hansie they
keep on stealing Christian who disz
Thunder they've hijacked his platform
and made it their own they're hardly any
issues for the CSU is falling short
honking the dark CSO creuset if it's
eating at this point only a miracle
could help Christian odor as incumbent
mayor of munich he's had to get used to
campaigning in the Bavarian countryside
they might like him in the state capital
but his appeal doesn't seem to travel
he just doesn't have the common touch
here that early carbon via initio we're
in a difficult position the people of
Bavaria are simply accustomed to voting
for the CSU they confuse the state with
the party even though this wonderful
state is the work of the Lord God not a
party Hoffman will do needful una parte
but together with its junior coalition
partner the liberal Free Democrats the
CSU has been running Bavaria from
Bavaria state parliament for decades as
both state premiere and party leader
Horst Seehofer is a powerful man he can
afford to laugh off controversy Seehofer
is the CSU and the CSU is Bavaria the
party seems invincible so much so that
it's ready to risk potentially
contentious proposals such as a car tax
for foreign drivers the electorate laps
it up
the german chancellor is less
enthusiastic but although she initially
opposed the plan on the campaign trail
she has been looking more willing to
reach some kind of compromise they're
both well aware that they need each
other the CSU is after all a coalition
partner in Merkel's government the issue
simply get glossed over it's a natima
the one sticking point you haven't
mentioned we'll sort something out the
Bavarian government is in good shape
thanks to the CSU Bavaria's should
continue to be governed by the CSU and
by US state premier that is our mutual
wish back and bother fighting huh Horst
Seehofer has nothing but praise for
Bavaria and for Mackel he'll be getting
his vote one week later yamba D'Aquila
Maggie I've seen a lot of Chancellor's
govern this country Billy brown Helmut
Schmidt helmet called Garuda Angela
Merkel in terms of both domestic and
foreign leadership Angela Merkel is a
very strong Chancellor ladies and
gentlemen not very strong Chancellor any
gunstar given this counseling but let
there be no mistake they offer let
smackle know that she needs him the
various mighty premier on her side